hello everybody hello hello look guys i have a perfectly good explanation today as to why i went to bed at 10 a.m you don't understand the new marvel rivals top 500 bad it's a dragon you don't
you don't understand it's a drag it's so cool and dragons equal lucky oh not really but like but it looks so cool so um i was so close you don't understand chat i was you don't okay i know i have i know i have a problem i i know i have a problem guys But this is the last one.
I swear to God.
Okay, I can't promise, actually.
You know I'm going to relapse.
I can't get it.
Even I know I can't promise that.
But no, I swear to God.
It's the last time.
It's the last time I'll do it.
I swear to God.
Don't understand.
When I see the badge and it makes my serotonin go, whoa, wee, wee, wee, yay.
But like, when I get it, though, when I get it, Right now it's not there.
Right now it's absolutely not there.
But I know when I get it, my brain will be like, yippee, yippee, yippee.
I know it's not there yet.
I can feel it.
I know my brain will be like that when I get it.
It's not.
Okay, so guys, you don't understand.
Guys, I swear.
I don't, I haven't done it in so long.
Just one more fix, chat.
Just one more fix.
So, I was three games off.
I was three games off when I started the grind last night.
Because, like, the day before, I won six games in a row.
And I was like, I got this is it.
This is it.
And then yesterday, I was three games off.
Three.
Today.
I'm six games off.
I lost seven games in a row.
When I started yesterday, I was like, I'm three games off.
I'm 500.
I'm gonna- And then I lost seven games in a row.
And I deranged two tiers.
I deranged two tiers.
I went from...
I went from Celestio 2 to GM 1.
But it's okay.
I'm back to Celestio.
I'm six games off.
I'm...
You know what they say.
99% of gamblers quit before they hit it.
I'm not quitting.
I have two days left.
Guys, no.
This is why I'm like investing so much.
two days left guys i have two days left it's possible you don't understand so it's in my reach guys i have two days left and it's in my reach i might be six games off but i i can do i think i can make it i think i'm so so um i may or may not have played rivals for 10 hours straight last night Um,
maybe, maybe 11.
Why were we even gambling?
I was this close, chat.
I was this close to stopping my stream.
I had no rivals.
I knew I knew.
I was like, no, just, no, no, don't.
Don't do it.
You know, they can't handle your rivals, Craig.
Don't.
Don't do it.
Give them the closest thing.
It's so high.
I was like, Clover Pit.
Time.
This is the closest thing to rivals that we can get.
Thank you.
I can't stand this woman.
Hope.
Thank you.
Come on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is what?
The fourth last one.
Thank you for the super chat.
I swear.
I swear to God.
I know I said that last.
for real that's why I didn't get raptured but this I swear to God this is it's a dragon it's so okay guys okay okay I let me show you let me let me show you how cool this badge looks real quick don't you don't understand I need to show you how cool this badge looks like and then you'll understand Also,
next season, it's a peach and it looks like an ass, but it's not as cool as the dragon.
I know, I was tempted, I was like, maybe I should try again next season so I can get the ass.
But like, because it's literally a peach and it's like shaped like a butt.
So I...
But it's not as cool as the dragon!
The dragon is so cool!
No, it's not as cool!
I know the dark circles are your skin, so you're fake, but I can feel like I was way worse than you in the super chatting.
No!
The dragon is so...
Okay, guys, guys, I'm not playing Rive.
I just wanted to show you guys so you all understand.
I need you all to be like, oh, I get it.
I get it now.
Like, no, you don't understand.
I need you to understand how cool it looks.
All right, look, okay.
I'm not playing Rive.
I swear to God, I'm not playing...
rivals i just want to show you guys why all right okay look look so this is the boring one that i have but look at this it's look at this a dragon look at this it looks so cool look how boring okay this is the one i have it's so boring like look at it's just a square but then bam oh my god it's Shiny.
It has a dragon on it.
No, it's much bigger than before, guys.
It's so much bigger than before.
It's crazy.
Like, oh my, look at, okay, look at how cool this looks.
Look at how fucking stupid this looks like.
Um, like a goddamn, what is this?
Like, the swarm?
Like, what is the, what the fuck is this?
seashell oh look it's a feather oh my gosh what the fuck that's just a feather a weak ass feather and then look at this wordy pulling from some fucking weights or some shit and is this a plant and then bam dragon look at that a goddamn dragon that shit is it is it tops all the other badges that's why i swear to god this is the last time Because I haven't tried top 500 in so long chat.
And to be fair, each season is like one month.
But I swear, at least five months.
Oh, that's cool.
The Dragon NFT JPEG has convinced me never.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just got here.
Are we still gambling?
Chat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't understand.
And that is... Actually, you do understand.
And that is why I went to bed at 10 a.m.
today.
And maybe potentially tomorrow.
That's why we also haven't had our schedule yet.
Because I was like, hmm.
Do I just make it?
Do I just...
Hmm.
Do I just make it?
All of these rivals.
Guys, I'm six games.
it's possible yesterday i might have been three games off but today i'm six games off so that means i'm gonna today today i will be closer maybe i'll secure it today we don't know that's the that's a gamble of it guys it's all about the gamble and 99 of gamblers quit before they hit it big and i ain't no fucking quitter so
This is not worst.
I swear to God.
This is the last time.
So yes, but don't worry.
I'm okay.
Anyway, let's play Clover.
Let's play Clover bit.
All right.
So I've been meaning to play this game for a while.
Um, it's basically like rivals, but like less, you can say that it's sort of like rivals.
It gives up the same gambling.
feeling um but it's like a rogue like gamble gamble game i don't know if any of my sound guys are alive right now what the fuck i actually click espanol oh no i can't read this they're like what language would you like to play and i was trying to tap out and i clicked spanish um guys any espanol speakers right now what does this say um datos de la demo oh wait that's the demo data i don't have i'm not playing the demo qui es importato de jogo oh my god i'm sorry i i need to refresh this i i need to refresh maybe if i reboot it it'll give me english oh please give me a
it please oh no okay no i know i never played okay maybe i could change of a visa the epilepsy oh epilepsy este ju will continue in petron lumin luminicos e luches okay um this is awkward we're i guess we're playing in spanish right now Wait, oh my god,
she's so, she's so good at Spanish, Espanol.
It's okay, we got this.
We can gamble in any language.
Gambling is universal.
All right, let's hope that I can.
It's okay.
Hola.
I thought there would be a settings.
Where the fuck is the settings?
I can't, it won't let me...
No, it won't let me press escape.
What do you mean?
I think I have to talk to him and then I can't escape All right, guys
All right, what do you mean?
All right, what does that mean?
Wanted to explain to see Explain to me in Spanish
Okay, all right, cool.
Okay, from contextual, I assume I place my money in the ATM because it says ATM.
I know, at least ATM, no matter where I am, at least ATM is still ATM.
If I don't deposit enough money, oh, if I don't deposit enough money, oh, I thought I said the cartel is going to get me.
I thought that's a cartel.
A cantidad.
I thought, I don't know why my brain was like, he's like, a cartel.
A certain quantity.
That's bueno.
I know what bueno is.
Ya vez, que pasa.
I don't know what that is.
Close enough.
Oh, fuck,
I fuck this.
I guess it's too much.
Okay, there's tickets.
Ticket.
Oh, that's a different language, too.
Let's try to put us to decide something, something.
My Oshi is so cultured.
Let's go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One tiki.
Tiki.
That's tiki.
Alfa now.
The con in the final round.
Oh my god.
I'm so good at Spanish.
I like instantly peace out together.
Alfa now the con around.
In the final round.
And then I don't fucking know what he's saying.
See.
Oh yeah.
Whatever.
Don't worry.
I figured it out.
Context clues.
Where's the is.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh, a juister.
I just, it's spent, oh my god, now I'm playing Korean.
I'm, dude, Dutch, Russian.
Okay, there we go.
We're fine.
I was gonna say, now let's, I guess we're playing Korean now.
All right.
All right, we're fine.
Okay, restart.
Yes, please.
all right i died no okay guys look um maybe they'll give me a tutorial again oh okay that's cool all right let's figure i did get the tutorial oh wait restart tutorial there we go wait okay next time i'll explain everything again all right there we go there we go now Now we got this Okay,
here we go talking Spanish like a beach cow.
There you go.
I hear you like to gamble Here you go.
All right, do you need okay.
Yes, please I got my I said I understood but I didn't understand anything Except for one One ticket goes somewhere.
I still don't know where that ticket goes.
I Listen carefully.
I won't repeat myself Okay, him talking in English is a new thing.
This is where you must deposit the coins you earn.
If you can't deposit enough coins, we're going to get a number of rounds.
Well, you'll find out.
I think we found out.
At the end, you'll earn interest based on your current.
You keep depositing to earn more.
And you deposit all of that early.
I'll reward you for it.
Oh, that's what it meant.
I was like, I know it's going to get tickets.
But like, how?
That was...
not enough context clues apparently also i bumped the overall sound a bit sound guy
all right you decide how many spins at the end you'll also see one clover ticket even more in certain conditions we're gonna spend your clover tickets to buy lucky charms they improve your odds of survival i know guys i know a lot of you might wanted me to play in spanish but like i don't think it would go very well i could barely read in english let alone the spanish instructions,
all I could really understood was in the final round.
Like final round one.
And bueno.
Yeah.
And that's all I understood reading the Spanish instructions.
Bueno.
And in the final round.
I don't think, and I feel like it's, that's not enough.
Remember to spend your clover tickets to buy lucky charms.
Okay, nice.
The restorative stocks for free wedding managed deposit that require coins at the end ATM.
Well, I'm done talking.
You won't remember all of it anyway.
All right, let's adjust our settings real quick.
How do I go?
Oh, there it goes.
Oh, I don't want to...
Oh, wait.
Uh, we'll go this way here.
Back.
What the fuck there is?
Alright, whoa.
Okay, that sense is way too high.
Why is the sense so goddamn high?
Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah, I bought a new gaming mouse pad again.
Um, oh, now it's so fucking low.
Um, because apparently you're supposed to, uh, you're supposed to...
supposed to get a new one every two years uh because then the texture of a gaming mouse pad um deteriorates obviously because your mouse is scraping it scraping it so you're supposed to get like you're supposed to replace it every two years so i had to order a new one
yeah no i hate the glass i don't i'm not hate i don't say hate it i don't say hate it but like i'm not i'm not i don't really like glass pads that much only because it's like way too smooth I use the my the hyen FX like the the fabric ones all right I'm ready okay wait the pot do I have three coins we already have the money oh wait no that's my debt oh fuck okay wait I don't have the money
JK I don't have the I don't have the I was like oh my god I can I can clear my debt oh my Oh, no, okay, that's fine.
I have less tries now, but that's, oh, okay, I need six.
Oh, no.
I was like, oh my god, I can clear my debt already?
Let's go.
All right, don't trust everyone.
Hello, mushy mushy.
What's this?
Log in.
One, grant, one check.
Oh, is that the, that's the roguelike part.
Oh, so this is my reward.
Wait, I can grab something now.
luck on next print lane oh let's grab red pepper uh green pepper oh seven for the rest of the let's do it oh i don't have tickets jk all right let's do it you know what seven how seven spins let's go i have seven dollars and i'm ready to Let's get up.
Don't worry.
Gamblers never quit.
Oh, plus two.
Two dollars.
Let's go.
Oh.
Five dollars.
Oh!
Alright, I made back my money, guys.
Look at that.
Let's go gambling.
I already made it back anyway.
No spins left.
I got a ticket!
Let's go.
Now I have $75 debt.
Okay.
Now I have $39.
We have a ticket.
I'll grab the train.
Train is lucky, right?
Alright.
Let's go.
Minus.
Alright.
Seven spins.
Let's go gambling.
Let's go something.
Let's go.
Oh, train.
That should work, right?
Yay!
Plus five.
Oh!
I went up.
Oh my god.
Wait, six?
Wait, six is more than three.
Guys, I can count too.
Okay.
Yay!
Oh my god, wait, my money.
It keeps going up.
Oh my god, and I got another ticket.
Oh.
Oh, I have one round left.
Oh, no.
Okay, wait, I forgot about that part of the game.
Wait, 24...
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is...
Ooh, that's...
This is a little awkward.
I'll buy this.
We'll just deposit...
Because we have three rounds left, right?
um oh wait you're right i should buy two looks like you discover new luck check out the terminal to learn more you got mail who's emailing me in jail oh my god isn't my secret am i okay those people that like send mail to like serial killers please get help like who was it i remember there was a famous serial that's still in jail by the way that has like that got married like got like a prison like got married to someone while he like he killed like i don't know like 10 women like 10 plus women or so okay there's that's a lot of them you're like please be specific that's a lot of them um was it charles vatson i know like he has like a wife outside of jail because like so many women wrote letters to him be like you're so um you're so handsome don't worry like i'll be different or some grant luck plus for for the next spin please like get help i don't even know what else to say like like please do not do not marry a convicted serial killer i like i can fix him yeah They're like,
no, you don't understand.
It's the...
There's the risk factor of him potentially murdering me.
Oh!
I got cherries!
Oh my god, I got 16.
I think I won.
I did it.
Wait, I did it.
That's enough, right?
Spin.
Spin, spin, spin.
Plus two.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
the double peppers guys oh that's a lot of cherries guys you cannot fix them guys you cannot or her you cannot fix the convicted serial killer oh my god I'm rich I'm root but I can be richer though
All lemons.
Guys, I can...
Guys, I can be richer.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
There we go.
How about another deadline?
You now need to earn the amount.
$200.
That's child's play.
Oh.
Okay, never mind.
I forgot that there's more.
Alright, what...
Do these come with me or do they disappear?
Oh, wait.
Hello.
sheet i can't quit now today's my lucky day clover manifests more often increase the value of patterns with three or less symbols by i'm thinking of some strategies three or less by their base oh wait double jack oh my god wait i can't quit two days oh is it clover's manifest should we get clover do we get clover or i'm thinking of some strategies Clover build.
I don't even know what's a good Clover run.
That's right.
I found my poor leaf Clover.
Don't worry.
My, my sponsor was like, uh, please, you told me you'd quit.
I'll be like, it's just one day.
It's just, I swear, it's just, it's just one day.
You're like, you were, you were five months sober.
I'll be like, I swear to God, it's just one day.
It's just, it's just one day.
Be okay.
Okay, it's now plus 14.
Just a quick one day relapse, and then I'll go back.
I'll go back to rehab.
I'll go back.
Just one, I can stop at any time I want.
Oh, plus seven.
Oh, got my peppers.
Yes, I did.
I got a minute to rehab.
And then you can, you know, you can, oh, hey, there's a voicemail.
This is all, oh, oh, that's a voicemail.
And then, like, you know, you can leave at any time you want in rehab.
Because, like, technically they can't, like, keep you there.
So then I left after I got in.
And then I was, you know what?
I don't need this.
And then I left.
all right
all right oh there's the clover um wherever you own wait do i get a clover picture more often for the rest of the oh wait do i get this i am too good yeah i went in used the bathroom and i checked myself out and then i came here and
i'll deposit 10 more Fuck it.
Maybe I can pause another 10.
Fuck it.
Or maybe one more 10.
Okay.
Oh, maybe if I think I can get in three spins.
I think I can get in three spins.
I think I... Oh!
I told you!
Okay, I lost money, but like, you have to lose.
Like, you know, you have to lose to win, you know?
That's how it goes.
You gotta lose.
to win.
All right, we got the clover, and then that's how it goes.
Sometimes you just gotta lose to win.
Wait, I have it enough for 200, anyway.
But like, what's the fun in that?
Maybe I'll deposit 10 more.
What's the fun in that?
Spend money to make money.
Exactly.
You know what's up.
Spin.
Alright, spin.
Nice, too.
I got three more spins left it's okay my pepper is activated and oh oh my god look at that oh i don't know what how much that gives oh plus 20 let's go i got a dot tail eight told you spend the win oh and i got plus two a little bonus too a little tip for my for for always oh my god look at all these clovers look at that guys spend money to make money i'm fucking drowning in all these I'm gonna fucking make my own Scrooge McDuck Bank account there and start swimming in the coins Alright Oh I have two left Okay do I buy Let's just buy a clover Oh wait We're true of golden modify Lemon,
lemon, no We going all in on the clover I don't know what that does but I'm going all in Yay Clover sweep Let's go gambling indeed thank you for the super chat remus thank you thank you all right six six six oh that's a lot of sixes uh deposits 33 uh hello can i tempt you with something i don't care about the price make two random lucky charms in the store free set your tickets to zero has oh yo i have zero good for me
half the base chances to manage okay wait maybe i should be left side dokey i'm gonna be left side dokey did it because all the the stuff is on the right side why is it all on the right no that's not left side where the fuck is that i always don't remember where left side dokey is There she is.
There she is.
Activate all your other...
Then apply the devious trait.
To random equip charm.
Wait, isn't that good?
I don't...
Uh...
I go with three for sure.
Three?
This one?
Or is this three?
I don't know how where you guys count.
Uh...
Uh, two?
Half the...
Oh, wait, yeah, wait, that...
Nice.
Yeah, let's do that.
Alright, 666.
Everything will be fine.
How much do I have left anyway?
Four left?
Look at my little clover pot right here.
Oh my god, triggered by a red button.
Bells manifest more often.
Whoa!
Check my mail.
I got mail.
You got mail.
When you score only one pattern with eye diamonds.
Okay, cool.
Press the big red button.
Where's the big red button?
There's a big red button in my... Oh, there it is.
It's right here.
Do I need to use it?
Okay, what was it?
Do I press it?
What do you mean it's kind of over?
It's never over.
Alright.
I'm ready.
It's never over.
Alright.
Is that it?
Do I just spin it?
Do I just spin it now?
Does it work now?
Oh hey, there's 666.
Can't be that bad.
Alright, here we go.
Lucky, lucky, lucky!
Look at that!
all right and my peppers oh oh
six six six bad i don't understand
lucky lucky lucky oh my god jackpot let's go The 666 take it and the 666 give it.
Let's go never punished What a comeback does it oh No But I
said never punished I
But I said never punished.
I don't understand.
And then I get punished?
If I say never punished, doesn't it mean I don't get punished?
Oh no.
Oh this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh no.
I need it.
I need to calm down real quick.
Oh,
shit.
I got pee.
Wait, I've jarred my pee.
What do I do with it?
During all patterns with yellow will trigger and this.
Oh, wait.
Does that mean there's something if I do a little poop?
Just a little poop?
There's somewhere there's a valuable lesson to learn here.
Wait, I don't understand.
Is this RNG?
How unlucky am I to get the sixth?
Wait, does this always happen in round three or is it just me?
Or is this just dokey things?
Is this... Is this... Oh, very unlucky.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's just... Just dokey things.
Okay.
Okay, that's good to know.
It's just... Just some silly dokey things.
Oh, yeah, lucky, lucky, lucky.
It says 1.5 chance.
That is not 1.5.
Okay.
Okay, nice cherries.
I need all I can get.
Oh my god, please.
Don't do this to me.
Okay, I don't see a 6.
I just have one more sprint.
Alright.
that's fine I'll take those oh thank God okay oh my god one round left oh oh my guys I don't think I'm gonna make it oh my god okay okay I need a 200 it's possible it it's possible I just need a I just need 200.
It's possible, you guys.
Spun money time.
Make money.
Okay, train.
Train activate.
Oh, let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Okay.
80.
All right.
We just need a hundred more.
Come on, come on.
Give me that big whammy.
Big whammy.
Big daddy.
Come on.
Choo-choo.
Oh, guys, guys.
I'm a little worried.
I'm a little worried right now.
Just a little bit.
Oh, my God.
My last spin.
Oh!
Oh, no.
My sponsor Wardview.
It's okay.
Guys, it's okay.
If I please, please.
I swear I can do it.
I can swear.
I can I can try.
I can do the money.
I can't get down!
Are you in control?
Yes, I am.
I am in control of my life.
Look, I've learned a valuable lesson today.
And that is that you never stop gambling.
If you quit, you quit before you hit it big, guys.
I learned a very valid...
It's because they forced me to quit.
And that's...
If I had one more spin, I would have made it.
That's right.
Let's go gambling.
I learned a lesson today.
And that's that I quit too soon.
And I should have committed.
I should have committed to it.
Activate more.
more or to have the golden wait plus one extra skit spin then luck plus four wait that's good the limit where's that sketchbooking yeah i was gonna say the coin seems really good all right i got mail all right so never quit ain't no quitter that's right i learned a valuable lesson today and that is i'm not some pussy quitter okay spin spin spin oh all right it's fine i can make it i need no quitter lord croesus thank you with super chat thank you thank you this is fine
yay 14 i'm like this grandma in las vegas casino right now i'm jambling away my my my children and grandchildren's inheritance.
What are you going to do with it?
It's like, I'm about, I'm going to die soon.
I might as well just spend it all in gambling.
Get that rush deck.
Get that rush.
Now that I'm old, this is the only rush I'll get.
They can get their own money.
They don't need my inheritance.
Real.
Take the horseshoe.
I didn't read what it did.
does i'm a good listener they're like take the horseshoe all right no questions asked okay i want two tickets to real i need that house grab then get a job i'm gonna sell my house so i can gamble more at last vegas no free will yeah no spins left
oh i cut it real close i just realize I did not have oh no I just realized I cut it real close there I even I forgot this is the final round oopsie oh do I have just enough oh wait nice pepper I have golden I'm living on the edge
Let's grant for the last spin, get the hand.
Oh, wait, but what about the kitty cat?
Plus two spins per round.
Wait, but the cat food gives me two spins per round.
Oh, wait, the call.
I can't quit now.
Can I borrow some green?
Oh, my God, wait.
Oh, my God.
Please, please, can't just...
I talked to my sponsor.
And he let me borrow he let me borrow oh my god, get the cat food He let me borrow like oh my god I could grab the hand let me borrow like like 10 grand and I told him like I swear This is like the investment of a lifetime and I can double your I can double the loan and like in like one day and I swear No questions asked me like are you sure because like this this 10 grand was gonna go towards my kids College to it fun and I was like bro I can get your kids five I can get your kids a full college education in me let me that 10 grand I swear bro I swear that 10 grand that thing I ain't gonna pay your kids fucking one year uh that kid that's not even gonna pay one year tuition bro I'll get you three years of tuition if you give me that 10 grand yeah bro he's gonna drop out anyway you think your kid he's gonna get goes through a full four three to four years of college bro we know we saw test scores.
We were lucky it was really good at rowing a boat.
Oh god, what?
I thought I would get lucky.
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
I'm like...
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
God gives their toughest warriors the biggest challenges.
This is just a test from above.
Okay.
process guys trust the process you're not trusting anything but how much was it okay 20 we'll buy the pepper just in case but nice oh total 15 oh there you go pepper activation oh yes i told you i told you to trust the process let's go 200
I like the steam reviews that was like, I had a gambling problem.
Thank you for making this game and it made for making my gambling problem worse.
Look at that fucking giant I can keep spinning.
I have four spins.
All right.
Let's go gambling.
Oh my god.
Another jack.
I told you, bro.
that I can fucking pay for your kid's full college tuition.
Oh, it's trust me, man.
I'm so rich.
But, guys, guys, I can be even richer.
Guys, I can make even more.
This is like an unlimited money glitch right here, an infinite money glitch.
Oh, my God.
If I just keep spinning, I keep earning money.
Because the more spins you do, More chances that you would earn more.
Oh, three in a row.
Three in a fucking row.
You are so in.
You win more than you lose.
Guys, I told you.
This is only the second round.
Oh my god.
Wait, what happened?
if i deposited fully again i don't remember guys what happens if i deposited fully chat do i uh
the streamer more tickets
oh oh
wait i can just
Oh my god, I forgot to answer the phone!
Oh, shit, I forgot to answer the phone!
I forgot about the phone!
No!
I didn't, I didn't, I was, I was so, I was, ended for too long.
I just wanted to, I needed to get the double away.
I needed, I needed, oh my god.
Oh, we're so, dead.
Oh, I got too close to the sun.
I got too close to the sun.
Chat.
I got too close.
It's over.
I was like, I got three jackpots.
I don't need nothing else.
This, but my money!
How will I run?
I can't roll, though!
I will be able to roll if I use it.
Wait, how do I roll?
How do I roll the machine?
Oh, ticket reroll?
Oh, I get a free roll?
Oh.
Alright.
Okay.
I trust...
Um...
I could just buy all of this, right?
Should I just buy all of this?
I might as well.
Because I haven't paid back the 10 grand yet.
Do I just buy it all?
Might as well I'm so rich right now.
I'm just gonna buy it all.
Buy the clover pet.
Oh, oh, I reached the limit.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I have a limit?
Okay.
I have three spins.
That's cool.
Oh.
Oh, let's go!
We're alive for a little bit longer.
Oh my god, 290, oh my god Can I stop?
It's okay, it's okay, I don't want to Oh, there's still 666 Oh, don't
Wait, it's all in, it's all in It's all, I can't Oh, no, please Please, oh, thank god Thank God, no, 666 Oh, thank God 154 Wait, another, I'm done, I'm done Please, don't make me, no, please, please, please, please, please Oh my god, let's go
Let's go Let's go Let's, 526 Let's, I'm just that, the jackpot, look at that Look at that.
I can pay off.
I can pay off that.
I can pay off his fucking kids' kids' college tuition.
Let's fucking go.
Wait, how much do I need for a spin again?
42.
Okay.
That's fine.
Just put that in.
Never punish.
Let's go.
Alright.
Let's grab the...
Is it better to do three?
You know what?
Let's see.
How much do I... Yeah, I just do three spins.
That's fine i have so many free spins right now okay it's just one one six oh that's just one six that's fine plus 18 and then the little pepper oh no my pepper is disintegrating so one more there you go oh i still have three more how many more spins i just i thought i paid for like three it's it's okay we're still here 229 one more spin there we go look at that until this comes it's all fun in games until okay let's let's is it good to do it earlier is it bad to do it early i still don't know uh no name thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you jr thank you the super thank you thank you survived my first sabrina carpenter concert last weekend there were so many people i panicked and ran out when i came back a guy fainted that was my cue to get the fuck out miss being introverted thank you super chat thank you thank you early equals more tickets depends on your bill but thank you super chat jr thank you they we enjoyed even though it knows a lot of people i still hope
you enjoyed a little bit of it a hundred if i deposit this you know look at the left of the bonus oh okay i don't know but you got like a lot yeah i do have a lot of tickets so it doesn't matter we'll do three more spins so we don't get the 666 let's chastity get the 666 oh thank god 667 thank god because we have technically technically we have the money
I just I'm just scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh 138.
Let's go But up but up but up but up but up I have one more spin Six six seven the neighbor of the beast Yeah Okay, that should be good Oh, I got so much money now I'm rich Okay all right and then one more oh and then one more yay 12,000 reach for your final reward is 12,000
oh, phone time please don't throw my increased charm space by one double jackpot's value lucky charms are just oh, I feel like Maybe an extra charm?
Or should I reroll?
I have so much tickets now.
I didn't get that.
Yeah, I'll grab this.
Alright.
Yeah, alright.
I got mail.
Okay, I have...
Plus one for the own now.
Make space for two more lucky charms.
Ooh!
Fancy!
Increase all symbols by their...
a base value of triggered after the second one resets at the end of every round.
Diamonds manifest more often.
Oh, briefcase.
It merely earned all.
Shit, let's go.
Is that charm?
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Yeah, that's free money.
Let's fucking go.
Wait, I should just deposit.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Deposit.
It's okay.
Uh, oh, we should get the red rock, yeah.
And I can't afford anything right now, yeah.
Alright, uh, just...
Alright, I don't know how much...
Uh...
Let's go gambling!
Oh, shit, I forgot the 666.
Alright, I forgot it's still in my...
Okay, okay, this is a little awkward.
I thought I'll leave!
I made one deal with the devil and now I guess my soul is forever his I can't believe it just I only did one little deal and now he just won't leave oh shit that button button time I forgot about the button oh my god that's sick that was so close oh my god it's 10 at least it wasn't at least it wasn't the other way around.
How has this been so unlucky?
Okay, one more.
Okay, this was a very unlucky spin, not gonna lie.
Alright, one more.
Oh, wait, that's a lot, right?
Oh, nice.
That's a lot.
540.
And I got another ticket.
I'm swimming in tickets.
Oh, oh, I'm like halfway there.
I'm halfway there.
Oh, living on a prayer.
Oh,
living on a prayer.
I can't, I can't, I can't get rid of all.
These are all so good.
okay oh use the red button at last spin i'm gonna do god the thing is increases the chance for 666 so i'm like oh acts
of training first rooms all right i'll put it in the drawer wait i don't have drawer we might know of oh this is the drawer oh you're right spend more make more you're so right I can't let my fear hold me back.
I can't let trauma hold me back.
Oh my god, 6-6-9.
Let's go.
You can't let my trauma get a hold of me.
Go big or go home, like they say, in the old country.
Am I?
Okay, not yet.
One.
There we go.
The nuclear option right here.
Go jackpot!
Let's fucking go!
And I doubled or nothing.
A thousand and twenty-nine.
Double- oh, wait, I have one more.
Well, that's awkward.
It gave me an- Oh!
Not awkward!
Oh!
Unskill!
Goin, get 2,209.
Oh, I have one more.
Oh, no.
I could lose it all right here.
Can I, sir, can I just, sir, I can deposit my money now.
Sir, I can deposit my money now, sir.
I know, you're so generous with giving me that extra spin.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
I can do it.
Oh, please.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Oh, please.
I don't want to spin anymore.
I'm okay.
I don't need a spin anymore.
Don't you just do it.
It's okay.
We're fine.
All right, that's enough.
Okay.
And then...
All right.
We can do one more spin.
Fuck it.
We don't need tickets.
But we're going to the moon!
Alright, let's go.
To the moon we go.
Buried me next to a casino so my ghost can gamble even when...
No, buried me... Spread my ashes on the...
on the slot machine.
so I can feel the gambler.
Oh my god, let's fucking go.
Yay!
Ooh,
that moon we go.
Pause it.
I got a draw!
Yippee!
See?
Gambling is.
good I get rewarded oh shit okay and then wait what does this mean what happens if I don't keep playing what happens if I click no do I just stop oh okay I like yo man we never quit info oh it's to put things inside okay double the value of increase triple the value of this oh i've been getting a lot of seven still oh that's like 99 of gamblers quit before they hit it but i haven't peaked yet i haven't peaked yet guys would i beat it already what what the i'm just that easy
Spread my ashes on the casino for so I can pull that salt stick just one more time.
Many thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One or two?
Oh, but then like we go all in on the seven.
But bro, what if I'm going all in?
I'm going.
You ever heard of sunk cost fallacy?
Yeah, but it won't happen to me.
You don't understand.
That ain't gonna happen to me, though.
Okay, what should I get?
The shrooms, right?
This one, right?
Uh, when you see at least one...
Which one do we get?
Shrooms?
Alright, shroom time.
Alright, we don't need a re-roll shop.
We go all...
Wait, how much is the gamba?
Oh, it's not that much.
Okay, I'll deposit some money then.
All right.
Let's go gambling.
That's fine.
Plus 24.
Come on.
Where's my lucky seven?
Come on, guys.
Oh, a thousand mama like you.
All right.
Oh, one six.
That's okay.
It's just one.
Plus 54.
It's okay.
I have the button.
There you go.
There we go.
Look at that.
With the power of the button.
And the lucky.
And the shrums.
Oh.
I guess I got another one.
When life gives you life.
you go gambling your life savings away oh my god and again let's go that's how it goes right that's the saying oh my god and more shrooms eight out i did it no spin wise words another last spin and another one and another last spin and did i hear more last spins you heard right baby
The last spins Never stop But
And shroom Shroom time Oh that was close That was so close That was actually so close Oh that's fine That's okay That's okay God take those lemons by the balls Oh Can't be a successful businessman if you don't commit Yeah, lucky time Oh my god, all in All in,
all in I told you, I told you The lucky seven I fucking told you All in, it works Oh my god, okay Oh, please, please, please, please Don't do this Oh, thank god Just one six, thank god Thank god Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I was so worried I was so worried they had Alright,
round round left and you are right, I know I'm right I know what I'm talking about
Okay We go in We have never punished Let's go Let's go gathering I can live here for the rest of my life.
Why am I...
This is a nice...
I got everything I need.
A toilet and a stop machine.
That's everything, right?
That's all you need.
And I guess water and food, I guess.
Okay, look.
I know this doesn't look ideal, okay?
I know that...
Um...
Might not have got a lot, but JK!
Oh my, I've got as much as I need it.
I got everything I need it right here.
Look, if I never have to meet anybody, why would I ever need it?
Basic hygiene is just for other people.
It's just for appearances.
Oh, Mushy Mushy.
Triggered by double the value of Clover.
Add the obsessive trait to a random lucky.
If I keep trying, the patterns will align.
Two?
I feel like I should double it, right?
Or three.
I don't even know what three...
What does the obsessive trait do?
what does the obsessive trait even do three is great all right we'll try it i don't know what it does but stop projecting your ideas into reality look bro you don't understand bro i'm not projecting bro i'm i swear i'm gonna be a millionaire bro and you're gonna regret it you're gonna regret it for not believing in me bro okay what's this pattern with non-yellow oh hey there's another pepper buy anything.
Oh, it's my money!
Oh, my God.
It's the money that triggers it, too.
Wait, that is so good.
That's actually so good.
Stonks?
Plus... Oh, wait.
I don't need that, actually.
I'm actually going to pause it.
3,000?
Alright.
Uh...
I don't have anything.
Is there anything?
Oh, I can buy this, right?
No.
Oh, I can't buy anything.
I feel like I'm...
It's already so good, though.
Yeah, I think that is actually the best, the best charm I can get it on.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
I don't even, I didn't even win anything.
Again, let's go.
And again, and again, and again.
Oh my god, it's teasing me.
That little six is just like, oh, what if we just get it?
It's actually, it's actually like, oh, but what if?
But what if we just get it right now?
Oh, that's really silly.
I was like, oh, you, you little silly guy.
You're so silly.
Good back, T's.
You're such a tease.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you thought we were going to give him another 60, didn't you?
I'm so silly.
You're so silly.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Two rounds left.
Alright, I'm just...
There's just a silly little bird.
I mean...
Should be okay now.
Alright.
Dump shrooms by stonks?
What a little tease.
That little six guy.
I like how the first time I got six, I got it like twice in a row.
Now they're just like, oh, just...
Remember that time when you got six, six, six?
Oh, oh, oh.
Remember that?
That was so funny, wasn't it?
After dropping a jackpot, damn, I know.
That's the worst part.
After I got the jackpot.
PTSD trigger right there.
But, um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um.
All right.
I literally have enough right now for, uh, I have, Wait, is that 3,330?
Is that it?
Oh, wait, that is the exact amount.
All right, we'll just keep spinning.
I said one more round.
It gave me hope just to take it away.
It's okay.
My thing will trigger eventually.
And again, and again!
But um, but um, but um.
put on put on put on come on come on where's my little seven oh where are you hiding little one come on don't you want to come home lucky number seven come back to a loving family all right oh i think an extra oh let's go come out to play
Oh, little tease.
Come on.
Alright.
Money, money, money.
People who said like...
Oh, wait.
Let's grab all that.
Oh, my God.
200k.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
It's getting crazier.
Diamonds manifest more often.
I found...
Increase the value by their...
Wait, what do we want?
We reroll?
I found a winning strategy.
please I'll give you anything one or reroll one okay all right oh my god the holy Bible if six is transform it oh my god wait I need that wait I need wait nice okay we got that oh my god wait but seven oh my god wait they're both so good oh my god but all my charms are so good wait do i need this wait i do oh my god everything all the items are so good i don't know oh my god oh my god they've all been so good to me they've all been
oh my god they've all been so good to me though they've all been so good to me oh no the the plus two spin has clutched it okay i'm sorry bro i'll put okay i have an idea i'll throw away the train
oh my god i don't know i feel like we don't need the train oh oh I don't know.
I feel like we don't need the train, right?
Alright.
Bye, train.
We're gonna destroy you.
And then we'll put...
We'll put you in the drawer.
And then what do we get?
The lucky seven or the Bible?
Guys.
Do we get the...
Train or the...
Do we get the seven or the Bible?
I can't get both.
Oh my god, they're both so good.
Seven?
Alright.
We'll grab the seven.
Okay.
We'll do that on the last spin, too.
Alright, this is it.
Let's go gabbing!
Okay.
Yeah, I have the seven buff.
You're right.
Yeah!
For thousand!
Okay, five.
Why didn't right away?
Oh shit, okay.
I didn't realize I needed right away.
Come on.
It says more sevens.
Why is there two?
What?
Why is there only two?
I want to spin.
Okay, I already put that.
They're like, do more sevens?
What about two sevens?
Like, see, now they have three.
Oh, my God, 25.3% chance for a seven.
Wow, I have more of a chance to get a seven than any other set, but it still gave me two sevens.
That's fucked up.
It still gave me two sevens, but technically I should get more.
That's what I'm saying
The max Oh my god look guys Now I have five seconds Oh look at that Oh nice Under 26 Okay 252 Bada bada bada Bada bada bada Yay 10,000 Oh my god I'm gonna lose it all aren't i this is too good to me i'm gonna lose it all that six it's like it's like we're like we're gonna get you i'm gonna get you i can feel it i can feel him outside my window just looking at oh my god the the third guy forgot the memo he he was like bro i thought you said next tuesday
It's at next Tuesday.
The other six got lost.
His GPS wasn't working.
Oh, no.
I have two more spins.
That's way too many spins.
Oh, oh my god.
He's like, bro!
Why are you still not here?
It's always the last six.
Today?
You mean today?
You got V for a specific...
Yo, we got a Google Calendar for a reason, bro.
You're the one that didn't put it on the Google Calendar.
All right, we made it.
The third six-point home.
The one guy that flicks out every time.
Let's go.
Can't believe it.
That's how you said tomorrow, bro.
But on, but on, but on.
13 000 jesus christ this is always because it's a build-up every time i thought it resets
oh my god it's getting too close for my liking oh my god 14 oh no no oh thank god he still did right he overslept again thank you guys like oh i'm sorry You, but you didn't read my text message, man.
I was confused.
They're like, guys, I think we gotta check on the third.
I think he's dead.
He hasn't replied to the text chain in, like, a week.
And I think he might be, like, dead or...
Oh, there he is!
He's like, hey, guys.
Like, just got...
Where did they go?
Checked.
They're not...
It's like, hey guys, I'm here.
I'm here for the spin.
Oh, there he is.
He finally showed up.
Nice.
Where is everyone?
He got the wrong date again.
Late by three business days.
Oh my god.
I don't want any more spin.
Let's go, actually, JK, JK, oh my god, another test, I don't want, this is, oh, this is too good to be training, I don't want, at least I'm okay, I don't want any more spins, oh, thank god, oh thank god, I got really scared, I, more, did someone say, more spins,
oh my god, so, I'm so nervous every time, Every time there's too many spins.
The whole board.
Lucky charms are discounted.
Double the value of diamond and treasure.
Should every roll chat win it?
But wait, there's more!
Uh...
Three roll?
Okay.
This time I'm betting on yellow.
Add the- what's the avid trait?
Two?
Or three?
I already have the obsessive trait last time.
Two or three?
Which is better?
It's like split.
I might have another charm with the obsessive.
Fuck it.
Three is better.
Alright.
Let's see which one got it.
Which one got the obsessive?
my god it's the horseshoe oh my god it's the horseshoe oh my god that's obsessive too the golden seven no oh my god i but all of these are so good they're all so good oh my i don't have room all of these have been good to me the crane oh my god they've all been so good to me
get rid of crane okay well what's in my drawer i don't remember i don't need the rock right i'll throw it away goodbye rock i don't need you no more okay um Do we get the seven or the stonks chat?
Sevens or the stonks?
Stonks or seven?
Are we betting on sevens?
Seven or...
Oh my god.
Plus 5% to your interest.
Let's do it.
All in on seven.
We're lucky number seven.
All right, here we go.
All in.
Oh, let me get the...
deposit some shit real quick fast.
Oh my god, that's it.
Okay, 200.
Okay, I can deposit another 50.
Okay.
Oh, okay, this is...
Wait, my thing.
Wait, why didn't...
Why is it not triggering?
Wait, why is it not triggering?
Oh, no battery?
It needs a recharge!
I'll...
You recharge, but I tell you to recharge!
Alright.
Okay, 21,000.
Oh, I need, like, 100k for a fucking win or some shit.
Okay, 21.
Oh, two more.
Oh, my God.
Oh, the sevens were so close to each other!
Oh, now they're all not...
All of them are not coordinating with each other.
They're all lost.
Nice.
21k.
Last roll.
No!
Let's roll!
Tell me.
It's over.
The run's over.
It's so...
It's so over.
No!
They finally coordinated with the group chat!
My 84k!
They finally figured it out.
Oh my gosh.
They finally found this.
They finally used the Google Calendar.
They finally figured out how to use the Google Calendar chat.
Oh my god, this spin is so unlucky.
This is actually a very unlucky spin.
Oh!
Golden cat!
Okay.
I have one more spin.
Come on.
Oh my god.
I want 21% chance for sevens.
But yeah, all I get are cherries.
I don't understand.
Oh, please don't do this to me.
Please.
Oh!
Oh, my world for us!
Yes!
Golden sevens!
Oh, and again, and again, and again!
Oh, my God.
Let's fucking go.
23k.
Alright.
Oh.
I don't know if I'll make it, though.
This is cutting it real close.
I have one roll left.
Oh.
Oh, oh, man.
This drop shrooms for stonks.
Is it time?
But they treated me so well, guys.
I can't.
It wants me to deposit.
Oh, I can.
Oh.
Stonks can save me.
But the shrooms have saved me so much.
Oh Okay Bye strums you've been you've been a good one You've done so well You've done so well for me.
Oh, here we go Here we go Okay, seven seven again seven again 60 I'm so picky six six six Please Keep going.
Okay.
500k.
I have six more rolls.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, again and again.
Oh, I need a 300k.
I have six spins to get it.
Oh, four spins.
Three spins.
Two spins.
Oh.
This has not been very good.
Where are my 7s?
I don't think so.
I have a 21% Oh, it's over.
Where are look at this percentage rate.
I do 25.3.
I don't understand.
Oh, where where is it?
Where
Where did it go?
What?
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
No.
I swear.
Lose, sir.
You know, I'm good for the belong.
Take it.
Oh, my God.
If I didn't get 666 on the last, I would have made it.
I would have.
I would have made it!
I would have made it if they didn't take all my money!
Okay, one more.
One more.
It's never too.
Oh my god.
I got so many items.
So close.
fortune taller Jesus Christ I'm like I'm like so much shit oh wait what why
do I why do I have it did what what is that even but it makes my dead go high what the fuck oh my god what the fuck What the fuck is that?
What is for the hardcore?
I'm fucking fucking hardcore running the shit.
Fuck that
Fuck that The coin It's always been so kind to me Oh my god, we can we talk it says you can't can we just throw it away?
Yeah corpse build fuck that shit how much was it seven all right we'll grab the coin and then we'll do three or spin so we can grab the hand i believe all right nice all right let's see and then we'll grab the hand and then we can deposit wait
And...
Boop!
Alright.
Spin!
Spin that wheel!
Nice plus...
Oh man, remember when I got plus 65k per spin?
Guys, I have a feeling that the 7 build was not the most ideal build I could have done.
I'm not quite sure why yet, but like, it's just a little feeling that I have that maybe the 7 build might have been the most stupidest thing I've done.
Just maybe.
I'm not too sure yet.
Chat will never lead me astray.
Yay!
Money, money, money.
It must be funny.
In a rich man's world.
Alright.
Okay.
I mean Can I just grab?
Nah, none of these God I don't know I should get it early so I can grab more tickets
Alright Let's just do more spins We need as much money as we can get I'm like debating if I want more tickets or not
We'll do it later I want But I don't It's fine.
Spin, spin, spin!
Spin that wheel!
I think it's for early.
We'll do it next round.
I just want money now!
I'm greedy.
Okay, 200.
Oh, phone call.
Bells manifest more often.
Are we doing...
Okay, Trev's manifest more often.
Double the value.
Oh, double or nothing.
Treasures manifest more often.
We want treasure.
Bet three.
Bell build.
Maybe.
Rerog.
Guys, I'm very poor.
I don't have a lot of tickets right now.
I know you guys think.
That was old dokey.
The dokey.
I'm the new and improved dokey.
With a bigger gambling addiction.
That's my improvement.
Oh.
Oh wait, no, we don't need that.
Wait, shrooms?
Okay, oh my god, they're all so good.
Guys, we can't do the seven again.
That one actually fucked us over.
Guys, we can't do the seven again, guys.
That actually messed us up.
Alright, we'll do shrooms.
How much is per gamble?
Okay, I can plus 10 more.
Alright.
Troon gang.
If we can't, if we get the money early, we'll deposit it early.
God, the cat food was so good to us.
Like, we actually, it clutched so hard.
Oh my god, this is not a lucky...
Oh, unless...
Oh, the plus five?
Oh, plus seven?
We're teed?
We get one more lucky roll?
Oh, there we are.
That's what I like to see.
See milaki!
Milaki drinks for everyone at the bar!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
But like, uh, okay, we'll do all of it.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh no, the Bible's gone.
I forgot it.
Oh, the Bible's gone!
Why the fuck would you have the base chances to manifest this?
Oh, I guess if you don't have these as your thing.
I forgot about the Bible.
Oh, wait.
We don't...
It's not that...
Wait.
Try double it.
I have the base chances to manifest closer.
Clare, I don't trade to all...
the charms in the store them that chances okay no
two okay two all right what do we have here oh clover voucher two clover gets me four okay someone ain't doing someone got their little cousin to do the pricing
to do the pricing for that.
Okay, clover and belt.
Free money.
Wait, what do we want?
We want a clicker?
A little bro is a goat.
We can get both of these.
Okay, we'll grab this and this.
Okay, the 666er is back, so...
Oh, that's fine.
I already got it.
Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Come on, you said a little repeater.
Where's my little repeater?
Where is it?
Come on.
Come on, little guy.
Don't be shy.
Come back.
I don't know what build we're doing.
There's a build.
My seven build didn't work for some reason.
I don't understand.
Click, click, click, click.
All right.
The pepper tab.
Nice.
Oh my god, 6-7.
Oh shit, that's scary.
All right.
No, no, no, no.
I mean, technically I can re-road this.
I don't really need it.
Cease.
I mean, a lot of cherries.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's grab it all.
It's my little collection.
Well, how much is that, bro?
28?
Okay, I can put more.
Alright.
Put on, put on.
My pepper.
Oh, I forgot to press it.
Oh!
Jackpot!
Jackpot, jackpot, jackpot!
Oh, and the- Oh my god, I got a new $200 runies right here!
Oh, please no, Peppa, please, please, no, 666, please, please.
I got a jackpot, please don't do this to me.
Imagine a casino actually had that, you know?
They had the, they have the fucking 666 feature.
Oh, I like me some Irish luck.
All right, nice.
One round left.
Oh, I made it.
All right, throw it out.
Fuck it.
Is any of these good?
The Scar.
Oh, I don't have any of that shit.
You get the Pentagon?
A pentacle?
Alright.
Fuck it.
I don't even know what this does.
Goes by one whenever...
Oh!
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Grab it early.
Fuck it.
Grab some more tickets.
I don't have a lot of tickets anyway.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do it early.
Get that shit out of here.
Wait, how many spins do I have?
Oh, one round.
You know what?
Finally, let's get some tickets.
Go next.
GG, go next.
Oh, it was just four?
I thought I'd get more.
And the ambitious trait.
Get rid of that cherry picture?
Okay, I'll get rid of it.
Increase the value of pattern.
Three?
Two or three?
I like how there's one guy that's spamming three and be like, If I keep spamming, she'll think she she won't get one guide and she
She won't know she'll get one guide
Two and three no one multiple guide nice catch
I'll do three then we'll see Which one did I give it to?
Oh, I gave it to my clicker.
Oh, that's not good.
Holy Bible.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I'm grabbing the holy Bible.
Gain one Reese free.
Oh, my God.
The Bible.
There is a God is watching me.
God believes in me, chat.
He's why he believes in me.
me see the church loves gambling please don't quote me on that but he has forgiven he is encouraging me to gamble more because it gives me one free restock every dead life so he is encouraging me to gamble even more he knows he knows i'm blessed now i'm blessed by the lord
With God by my side, anything is possible now.
He has blessed this run.
Look at that.
Take the slots, Jesus.
I know there's a big bad slot machine calling for you.
No!
How did he leave me already?
He already left me.
God, I thought you were by my side.
What happened?
God, where did you go?
God.
God has left the church.
cat why have you i thought we were cool bro bro i thought we were cool he took one look and dipped bro i thought we were cool
bro it happened i already have enough
good jk la mal
He actually jinkin' about B.
It's like, I'm out.
Even I can't fix you.
God, no!
I'm so sad.
I thought we were homies, bro.
I thought we cool like that.
thank you for the super chat thank you it's like jk them out i might as well grab this i have one more slot two more activation okay this guy this guy is leaving soon i've had a confession with you it would have forgiven your sins or i think it was a super chat thank you i don't know what i did wrong like what could i I'm possibly done wrong.
I thought we tight like that, bro.
God, I thought we tight like that.
Alright.
I think I have, like, one more pepper before I finish eating it.
Alright, last spin.
How is that lucky?
It's just cherries!
Cherries again!
Alright.
I have just enough.
I still have this one.
One pepper.
Uh.
There we go.
I mean, I'm halfway there.
Halfway there.
Ooh.
Living on a prayer.
All right.
I might as well double that.
I have so much cherries.
I feel like one would be the most obvious, right?
i keep getting cherries or two one re-roll really i i always get cherries be right back okay look at this 20 cherries and lemons okay yeah no we're we should get we should we should grab cherries we should yeah i'm doubling the value i have a I didn't realize how fucking...
I got a lot of cherries, apparently.
Where's my Bible?
Where's my plus one restock of the Bible?
Where is it?
I was done.
Okay, let's get rid of...
Oh, this is the way.
oh my god you mean like i thought i thought it meant like if it dies he actually pissed out yeah i can't believe he actually pissed out we got the dokey we're gambling for today calm thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right we'll get lucky cat I can't believe he pieced out on me like that,
bro.
What happened to homies for life?
You thought you'd know someone, you know?
You think you know someone.
But you don't.
You don't know them.
Alright, it's for the treasure build.
Alright, we'll throw the sphere away.
Personal trainer is good.
How good is it?
Not well.
of.
I don't understand.
Now I get zero cherries.
It's just all treasure.
Alright.
It's like, oops, all treasure.
Person, for the Reposition Mod, by decreased by...
We get this?
Oh no.
Take my college.
You're my favorite gambling at addicted me.
That's not an addiction.
It's a lifestyle.
That's pretty good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do I get rid of?
All my shit is good, though.
Do we get rid of this?
I feel like we don't...
I feel like we got a lot of treasures, though.
I don't know.
Do we get rid of this or...
And get the personal trainer?
I feel like they're all pretty good.
It's a light.
It's a dedication.
It's a hobby.
Draw the orb.
What's in my... What is that?
Oh, wait.
Do I have... Oh, I don't have anything in there.
I'll draw it.
And then I'll grab the personal trainer.
Alright.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God number three.
is not reliable.
Jesus Christ.
That's what I like to see.
I'm not making it.
My last run was so good.
My last run was actually perfect.
Oh, thank God.
He just didn't show up.
He's like, maybe he's just one hour late, guys.
But he just never showed up.
Nice.
Lucky cat, 3,000.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, oh, diamond.
Here we go.
And again, 2,000.
Oh, wait.
I got another lucky spin.
Oh, the more diamonds.
Get them, girl, some diamonds.
Oh, my God.
This is a lot.
Oh, and the lucky.
Oh, wait.
I just made everything back.
Oh, look, diamonds.
Look at that.
some diamonds here.
Alright, we'll wait here.
Alright.
I think we can.
One more row.
I mean, we made it.
This is just... This is just for the fun of it.
This is the passion part.
Where the lemon cherry been?
Oh my god, I got a new item.
A girl's best friend.
I'm just doing it for the passion already.
already.
Those sixes don't scare me.
I know the third guy is unreliable.
He doesn't look at the group chat.
I ain't scared.
Nice.
It's just a side hustle at that point.
Yeah.
Yeah!
33.
I'm practically almost there.
Yeah.
I'm almost there already.
Double the value.
Increase the charms.
Oh, wait.
We should get two.
I'm waiting two.
I need more and more charms.
I'm so hungry.
So hungry.
Every last pattern triggers one more time.
Wait, we should get stonks.
Stonks go up.
Oh, wait.
We practically make it.
Alright, let's just...
Does that go all the way?
I don't know, I can't count.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
I already made it.
So this is just for the fun of it.
Yay!
We spin, spin, spin.
Oh my
Jackpot Running in the money
Oh my god, it's keep going.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
ultimate jackpot Ultimate jackpot X2 Oh my god, it keeps going oh Oh, oh Guys What if it gives these guys?
I think Oh my god, please don't do this to me.
Oh
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Oh That's so scary.
Oh, it gave me all that Sarah thorned not today Satan not today Oh, that was so scary That was so scary.
Holy fuck.
He got three.
No shots.
Oh, the last six was fought.
They had pride.
I slipped some cash under the table that you, I'll give you a 10% cut.
Okay, wait until you get into notation summaries.
Yeah, there you go.
Super chat.
Thank you.
There was a meaning to...
That's right.
The third stick is a dirty cop.
Nothing bad ever happens to Kennedys.
Wait, how many rounds?
Oh, I have two rounds left.
Keep going.
That's crazy.
Okay, I can keep going.
Pay them off.
really good oh wow minus zero oh got it all the way for spin they're like bro now you show it's like i'm sorry i thought you told you you messaged me and said get your ass here right now and i did bro this is not what you want bro
i spin too late
I can't.
Too slow.
Satan.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
Nice.
We're slow for the dookster.
Alright.
We have another spin.
I can't believe I got the ultimate jackpot.
That was crazy.
I didn't even know numbers can go that high.
Keep gambling.
Gotta keep gambling.
I gotta keep going.
Gotta keep going.
My numbers are only going up.
It keeps going up.
It will always go up.
It'll never stop going up.
It'll keep going up and up and up.
Oh, oh, goodbye personal trader.
We had a hard attack.
Alright.
Is there anything I can buy here that's worth it or not?
Nah, it doesn't seem like it's worth it.
We'll just put it all in.
Yay!
I got a reward!
Let's go!
Alright.
Let's unlock another drawer.
Yes.
We never stop.
Hello.
add the uh to a random double the lemons oh wait we want more lemons when life gives you lemons
congrats to the lucky bird but you had it good for too long punch thank you for the super chat but but more lemons seven picture okay last time i committed to the seven it didn't go so well I feel like we can refresh this.
At the Golden Modifier.
3 is crazy.
This one?
We get a lot of them.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's like, do we even get...
Obaka 24%.
Okay.
We should grab that then.
You know what?
I have so much money.
Yeah, let's fuck it.
Let's go.
Uh...
Like, we practically made it.
Diamond photo?
Oh, shit, you're right, I didn't even see it.
I don't know what to get rid of.
Everything's been so good to me, sir.
Everything has been so good to me.
It's like, what can I get rid of?
Nah, everything has been good to me.
to me so far.
I feel like I use the clicker a lot.
Do I have anything here?
I don't need treasure photo for my build.
Okay, let's do this first.
And then what?
Oh, this one wasn't a good spin.
Maybe it's the last spin.
It's the last spin that matters the most.
Okay, for the mushrooms, all right, uh, all right, let's grab the diamond, not screws, you take those lemons and you squeeze them back into life, guys, I think it was Richard Warren, thank you, thank you, thank you, when I get, when I get extra, I go,
go full French, okay, okay, what do we, what do we table?
laughs in French.
Do we get the diamond?
Is it worth it?
Is this worth it?
Or is this spear?
Oh, wait.
Diamond and treasure.
Wait.
Okay, we should grab that.
What do we shove?
I know, but what do we get rid of the clicker?
But he's so upset.
He's ambitious, though.
Oh, wait.
Put it in drawer.
Okay, put it in drawer.
And then...
He quit.
Okay.
Yeah, because our treasure.
We want the treasure.
Clicker good?
But what do we get rid of?
I don't know.
They're all so good.
Stongs?
Put the stongs away?
Or clicker better than shrooms?
Okay, put it in drawer.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's go gambling.
but um oh nice 780 and again and again 8,000 and again keep going always keep going oh my god it changed the seven this is the first time i've ever seen the seven oh my god
Why does Doki turn Italian when she hits the jackpot?
Thank you for the super chat kill.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I feel like the shroom has done more.
I'm not sure yet, though.
I feel like I feel like I got more stuff from the shrooms.
Wait.
Let me look at it.
I feel like the shrooms have done so well.
Yeah, I'm going to replace the clicker.
all right i just feel like the the shrooms have done so much for me
okay we got the seven we're so rich now i don't really care what we get like the double the double has no oh my god oh they're like has no what huh has no what tokey i just know i didn't say anything i
say anything i didn't mean it
i i don't know what you're saying
all right nice that's what i thought
double jackpot's value i can't quit now oh i'm so lucky though Okay.
Okay, Bella and Clover, no good.
Alright, double jackpot.
Last, then this last street, then discard this charm at the end of the just as many.
Being one if only one transforming it to the most.
Wait.
Oh my god, they're all so good.
Wait, they're all so good.
Oh my god, what do I get rid of?
They're all so good.
so good oh my god guys okay i'll get one oh my god this oh
my god the necklace is so cracked but i have nothing all right we get rid of stonks is it time i think it's time to put i think it's time we gotta put the stonks in the drawer and then we'll grab the necklace there you go there you go This is it.
Oh, wait, I already have enough.
Let's just...
I already have enough anyway.
Alright, there you go.
There you go.
Spin that wheel!
Oh, Stoxia State up buff the cat?
Okay, now I got nothing.
Okay, we need...
Okay, so should we get rid of...
Oh, nice, I got more.
Songs to make cat better.
Oh my god, but the cat in the shroom just gave me 16k.
The cat in the shrooms gave me 16k, guys.
Nice.
More treasure.
Again.
Oh, and again.
And shrooms.
And then 90k and lucky roll.
When it says plus seven luck.
Like, what was my luck?
Like, Negative 99?
Look at this.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
But this was so good to me.
They've always been so good to me.
I don't know.
I don't know what to get rid of.
And I had the coin too.
The monkey paw, girl.
Oh, I don't know.
Everything is so good.
Okay, we'll put you...
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
I can't swap.
I can't.
I have to actually get rid of something.
Oh, my God.
Did we get...
I'm going to get rid of the...
clicker i'm getting rid of it goodbye clicker and then put you in here there we go it's fine i've technically made it already we'll try it out oh my god ever since i okay okay it's okay we got 20 oh my god 27 000.
oh Wait, this is so worth it.
Wait, what did I even finish?
I don't even know.
One round left.
What?
I don't even remember what I put away.
Oh, I put away that coin.
I don't need no coin.
Let's go gambling.
Nice.
22.
It's alright, I made it.
I made it, baby.
That's what the, I'm living the American dream as a Canadian.
This is just passion now.
Oh, and then 39,000.
Oh, lucky spin.
Lucky spin.
She's God-French.
Someone stop her.
The best of Both worlds.
Okay, okay.
This is where I didn't break a million last time, so Sevens Manifest Moral.
Increase the value of patterns with three or less symbols by their Wait, what do we want?
Oh, wait, there's a doll again.
Let's see.
45%.
Wait, do we one one okay grab one first and then okay i don't think any of this matters i have the god run right now all right i don't think we need any of this right i don't have room anyway so it's fine i have no room for any of this it's all about the spins baby
about the spins baby let's go let's keep going nice lucky roll lucky roll lucky roll oh come on shrews yeah we're shrewming tonight but not the illegal cat not the legal cat guys not the legal for legal reasons okay oh we're so close we're gonna break a million we're gonna break our record click click click click click click yeah a hundred and nine we made it back we're millionaires we're gonna guys we're gonna be millionaires yes oh thank god oh thank god okay Oh,
yes!
The cherries.
The cherries coming in, clutch.
And then a pentagon.
And then $82,000.
Let's go.
Okay, one more.
One more.
This is to seal the deal.
Oh.
We need 20k.
We just need...
20k.
I'm so tempted to buy this.
I'm actually, I'm so tempted to buy this just in case.
Do we buy this for insurance?
Do we get this?
I don't know.
You know, nine, nine, nine, 20k.
This kid all be ruined.
Okay.
But what do we get rid of?
Okay, we get rid of Okay, alright, because I don't trust this.
Alright, we grab this for insurance because we get three spins and we get...
Oh, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't fear the 777.
I'm sorry, don't fear the 66677.
So, I met Spider-Doki, can't come for the sad dragon.
I had a pretty rough start for a week and I feel pretty disappointed for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you feel better.
I hope the stream cheers you up.
for you like dragons are always here for you i think you have a super chat thing you think yeah popio thank you a super chat thank you thank you of course you can happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear popio happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday don't worry this spin is for you i actually i forgot to okay i forgot to put mine okay we lost the chart.
All right.
I forgot about buying the chart, but this spins for you!
It's all on you, Bopio.
That's right.
This is the birthday spin right there.
Right here.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh, come on.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God you saved me.
You continued my gambling lifestyle for another day.
Thank you.
It's all you.
Remember, you continued my gambling addiction.
Remember that.
Do I buy a personal trainer?
I don't know.
Like, I don't know what to get rid of.
Because everything is good.
The cycle continues on.
Maybe we'll bench the lucky hand.
He has not been so kind to me.
Six million?
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, we need more treasure, right?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Other than...
I need money or I found a winning strat too.
Alright, we commit to his treasure tower.
Oh, the chunky cat.
Wait.
You're just a regular cat.
But you are chunkier.
It's so fat.
Of course it's got a feeling.
You can wear the diamond.
Wait, sell necklace?
But he's so chunky.
Big, look at him.
You gotta go.
I'm sorry, buddy.
We're gonna put you in the grinder because you're...
Look at that.
That's a chunky-ass cat.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I think I was like...
Oh, I was like, wait a minute.
I don't think I have money anymore.
Oh, my God.
okay nice 23 000 that's not nice that's not good enough oh no this is not good enough oh this is not good enough oh this might be over oh oh oh we go again okay come on cat come in here cat all right this is oh this is bad i think our run is my This is not looking so good This is so Okay Okay,
it's again Okay, chunky cat will come in clutch I believe in the chonkster We're gonna get seven Oh, wait, wait, is that seven?
I can't count One, two, three, four, I don't know Does that count as seven?
Again And again, and again And again!
And it keeps Going!
Oh my god, I've only had The necklace, I've only had This is the...
Oh!
Yabba-dabba-dew!
Alright.
That's fine.
Guys, if only I had the necklace, though.
The necklace would have actually been so good during that...
during that run.
Okay.
Oh, wait, I think I made it.
Wait, I think I made it.
I made it.
Yeah.
I was like, is my map correct?
Oh, it's six million.
Oh, I, I, I've thought this said three million.
I was like, guys, I made it.
Yeah, I'm not even close.
Oh my God, guys, I'm so close.
Look, I'm so close.
I thought, guys, I, I guess I don't think I make it.
I don't, guys, I don't think I make it.
I made it halfway.
Let's go, Gav.
I was a little blind there.
We just need more of that, sir.
More of that, please.
Oh, this is not looking so good for the dog stare.
Oh, this is...
If I somehow just hit the most ultimate jackpot of my life.
Oh,
oh, no, no, no, please.
I'm so close.
Oh, I got a B before they killed me.
All right.
We had, we had a really good run.
We had.
Gotta use...
Yeah, I got a horse!
Oh my god, there's so many items.
Wow.
Oh, hey.
I have a deal for you.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I got a horse, though.
What's the one trick code?
Hey, that's me!
Okay, so diamonds.
Where the fuck is what's the horse what the horse do why can't i jump just jump and grab it you know what i think this is a good time to call it guys because i had to go to my other gambling lifestyles
maybe i'll stream later today i'll see how i feel i'll see how the games are like
Maybe I'll stream.
No promises
Arthur, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This was a good warm-up though.
This was a This was a really good warm-up to what I'm gonna do later tonight.
Now time for the real You know, I had some pretty good life.
I believe in myself now for another one this was a good i had such good luck here i believe it see it gambling is not wrong
but i hope you guys all had a great time watching um on thursday we actually have a sponsor it's a collab sponsor i don't know if i can announce it you'll see on the schedule i'll post the schedule either before i go in deep or after so maybe in the morning tomorrow i don't know you'll see the schedule tomorrow morning or today before i before i go into it but i hope you guys all had a fun time watching i always have great time streaming for you guys i'm sorry this will be the last i swear to god this will be the last i only it's two days it's two days left guys it's a dragon it's a dragon
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys all have a fun time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you still, for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye, bye.